I've heard people like oh they need
leadership they don't have a leader or
they'll say like because they don't
listen to Al Horford I actually think
they do have a leader in Al Horford I
actually think they do listen to Al
Horford however I think they get to a
certain point to where Al Horford can no
longer a part of leading is also like
speaking from experience experiencing
things and knowing what to draw from to
get through that situation and Al
Horford has the same finders experiences
that all of those guys have so you get
to a certain point and like if you don't
have anything to draw from then either
your guys don't necessarily feel it when
you're speaking that like from that
perspective or they see through it